はい どうぞ  自殺する時に車にひかせたら車に乗った人は罪になるんですか？ ん？自殺する時に車にひかせた
誰がやったんですか？ 車に乗って自殺しようとした人が車に跳び上げようとしてから
車に買った車に乗っていた人は罪になるんですか？ 飛び込む
飛び込むっていうことだよね
車に  車 車を運転した人は知らないですよね
知らなくて でも勝手に飛び込んで来て
車が結果的に自殺  その場合は罪になりませんよ
はいはい  あのキリスト教なんかでいう自己犠牲他のために死ぬとか
そういうようなまあまあその一種の自殺かと思うんですが
身代わりになって死ぬとか
そういうようなものは仏教の立場からいうと
どういうふうに評価するのか
そういうのはケースバイケースで考えるものであって
あの 基本的な法則は自己犠牲は良くないって
自己犠牲っていうのは怒りのかぶりなんです
基本的には だからはっきりお釈迦様がこの人のためやと思って自分のことをお粗末にするなよとはっきりも教えているので
だから自分が犠牲になって他人のために何かするっていうことは
自分がそれほど頭が良くないんですよ
人間には能力あるし 知恵が知識があるし
いろんな工夫できるし
いろんなものを考えられるし
ですから知恵使うことが一番いいことで
だから自分が犠牲にならないで人を助けるのは正しいんです
泳げないのに川に飛び込んだというと
もうもうこれ評価できんですよ
だって溺れてる人も助けてないし
自分が死んでいるし だから一人が死んで一人が助けたっても
どう評価できますかね
例えばまあ 孫が川に まあこれあったケースですけど
川に落ちたところでおじいさんがすぐ飛び込んじゃって
もう孫は助かったんですけど
子供っていうのは浮きますから
おじいさんが死んじゃったんですね
だから それで助けられた孫がそれからどう考えればいいんですかね
生き方は 負担でしょ 孫に対しては
おじいさんはちゃんと飛び込もうと思って飛び込んでいるんじゃなくて
そこには何もその本心とかそういうのは働いていないから
いや これはすごい愛着ですよ
瞬時に飛び込っても もう強烈な愛着で飛び込むんです
だって私も同じことやりますよ
愛着はないんです 人を助けなくちゃという
その時は  瞬時に飛び込む時は思わず飛び込むから何も働いてない
それだったら無知でしょうし
無知でしょうし うん だから結果それほど美しくないんですよ
だからもし孫が助けても
だから孫はそんな助けられたことに対して恩義を感じたり
非を感じたりする必要はない
といったっても そんな我々勝手に思ったっても
肝心な孫が大人になればなるほど
自分が元気になればなるほど
おじいさんのおかげで死んだおかげだということになるでしょうに
それぐらい親を思わないととんでもないでしょう
まあまあそうじゃない
そんなことはと 死んだのは当たり前だと思えない
当たり前と思うというんじゃなくて
負担に思ったり  負担になる
いくらなんでも 私は今までに自分の母が自分にももうもうそこに食べるものないのに
自分の食べるものを一部分けて
私がお腹がすいているんだから
私と弟とかね 一応みんなに分けてあげたのに足らない
元気だから 母自分のお皿から二人に分けて分けて食べさせるんですよ
考えると涙が来るんですよ
その時は全然気にしなくても
母が食べさせるとえらい美味しいし
で 大人になってくると
あれ お母さんのご飯の一部でしょう
今も自分の家では平気でそんなことやってますけど
今はそんな問題ないんですけど
どうしても姉の子供たちでも年なのにお父さんご飯食べるとそばに行くんです
それでお父さんのお皿からもう食べさせるんです
まあこれはいくら年を取っても
それをみんな喜びますけど
でも当時はやっぱりそれは考えなかったんですよ
だからどれほど母がね
子供のために ...苦労するのかと
考えると悲しいんですよ
自分がその分親孝行したのかと
だからそれが負担になりますよ
普通な人間であるならば
いえ そうなりませんよ
どうせどんな人でもその時は衝動で飛び込みますよ
それは避けられない どうせ孫になってあうと
自分の子どもになっちゃうと
もう愛着に決まってるんだから
知恵は働かない だからこういうもう罠なんですよ
人生っていうのは 私には愛着なくて人を助けることできるかもしれませんだけど
家族の中ではもうそれはできない
愛着で飛び込む その瞬間で頭が動かない
それでもう五分五分ですよ
損していくらか得するというよね
それまた後で負担になる
どうせ愛着は苦しみの結果になるのはもう避けられない事実なんです
それで犠牲になるということはそんなに立派なことじゃない
しかし ケースバイケースで
例えばまあ村がもうダムが壊れて洪水になって
みんな死にかけ死ぬかもしれませんし
そこでダムにダイナマイトをかけた方が別なところで壊しちゃうと
村人みんな助かる もう逃げる所もないんだから
もうダムを壊すしかないというケースを想定すると
それは一人の人がとにかくもうダムをもう割れがひび割れが入ってあって
危険の兆しで命がなくなることは承知の上で行って
ダイナマイトをつけて爆破する
自分が逃げるつもりでしたけど
もう逃げられ逃げきれなかったと
それが別に その人はもう別に知恵使わなかったわけじゃないんです
できれば逃げたかったんですけど
まあ逃げられなかっただけで
それで自分が犠牲になったんですけど
大勢の人を助けたんですね
そこで引き算したっても
もうそんなに悔しくはないんです
だから犠牲を自己犠牲を美徳するのはもう心理学を知らない世界なんです
自己犠牲もやっぱり結局は怒りのかぶりにはなりかねません
代わりにこういうことはあります
自分がまあまあ自分の命もかわいいと思いつつも
いろんな人を助けたり
いろんなことはする 人の助けることに喜びを感じて
もうしらしらす 自分のことは忘れてしまう
自分がもう例えばもうもうろくにご飯も食べてないわ
もう寝ることもできないわ
大勢の人を助けなくちゃいけない
だからみんな寝かしてあげて
みんなにご飯作ってあげたりして
もう必死で頑張るんですけど
まあこれで自分が結構体肉体的に損耗している
それはもう別にかぶりじゃないんです
ただ 本人が相手を助けることで喜びを感じる
だからそんなことどうでもいいやということ
こんなことやっていられないんだと
寝ていられないんだという気持ちになります
そういう場合はかぶりじゃないんです
美しいんです しかし その場合でも罪を犯しちゃうと罪なんです
犠牲になるんだからといって罪を犯すことは認めていないんです １０
人を助けるために３人殺したそうと言ったっても ３
人殺した罪は罪です だから自爆テロなんかはもう明らかにもう罪なんです
まあ犠牲になるっていう場合
時々医者が研究して薬を作って
もうこれはまず動物を実験して
それからもうそれをうまくいったところで
何年も経ったところで何の問題もないんだと
それからもうゆっくりゆっくり人間にもチェックしてみて
薬の許可してもらうという場合は
時々医者がもうこんなのはもう時間かかるんだと
早く薬を使った方が人間の役に立つんだと思って
自分実験台になる それは自分が犠牲になっちゃうでしょ
危険性もあるし それは自分で感じて
何が副作用はどういうものかとかね
それはちゃんと考えて
早くも薬を作ったりする
それは自己犠牲行為なんですけど
医者が早くももう末期治らないこの不治の病には薬を作りたいという
それで大勢の人々を助けたいと
一旦薬ができたら どれぐらい人を助けるかとわからないという気持ちでやるならば
その自己犠牲は評価できる
自己犠牲を評価する大乗仏教の物語があるんですよ
ジャータカ物語 これ大乗のジャータカ物語で
我々仏教ではないんです
それはヴィャーグリージャータカサン スーリョーで言うんですけど
虎の物語なんですね で
なんとか菩薩がもう森で修行すると
虎のメスが子供を産んで餌を取れない
獲物を取れない それであまりもお腹が空いて
メス虎が子供を食べようとしているんです
それを見た菩薩はそちらに飛び込むと
飛び込んで自分が犠牲になると
あんなの菩薩行じゃないんですね
知恵で考えるならば あんた修行した方がいいんじゃないかとか
あんた人間でしょうと
あれ 虎でしょうと どうせ命はそんなに長くわけじゃないし
人間というのはもう４０歳ぐらい
当時どうかわかりませんだけどね ６０
歳 ８０歳で虎っていうのはせいぜい２０ ３０
歳ぐらいでしょうし 虎を助けたくて虎は何するんですかね
他の動物を殺すしかないでしょうに
だから余計なことに手を出さない方がよかったのに
それで自分が死んじゃって
虎の子供たちを助けたところで
虎の３匹とお母さん虎がそれからまた鹿を食っちゃって食っちゃって元気でいるということになるんだから
こういうのはもう何の意味もないんですね
だからそういうジャータカ物語さえ仏教ではないんです
自分が犠牲になる物語はありますけど
見事にそこら辺で微妙に計算しながら計算しながら
犠牲が対価になるようにするんです
例えば 国の王様に菩薩が国の王様になって
それでジャータカがいくつかあります
で 殺生しないで政治をやる
それをわかったら 隣の国があの人は殺生しないんだからね
軍隊は飾りもんやと だからあの国を取ろうではないかと軍隊を持ってくる
そこでそのジャータカ物語で
この軍隊は王様に報告するんです
王様の国はもう攻められているんだと
私たちにとっては王様ほど立派な人はもう現れないんだと
だから我々は戦いますよと
力ありますよと あの小さな国よりはと
許可してくださいと 言うと
菩薩は君らはね 私のために蚊が吸うぐらいの血も流してはいけないんだと
私のためなら だからやめなさいと
で 攻撃しない で 攻撃しない
で それで軍隊は敵軍隊は国に入って
宮殿に行って 何のことなく王様は捕まっちゃう
で 王様が決めるのは まあ誰か政治やるでしょうに
別にどうったことはない
それが 私が王でいたいんだからって
なんで人を殺すのかと
私が死んだっても 他の誰かが王になる
だから私のためには血を流せないんだということで
自分が犠牲になる だからそれは評価できる犠牲なんです
それで国民一人も死なずに死んだんだから
たとえ隣の国に支配されるはめになっても
敵の何て言いますか 抵抗しなかったんだから
敵軍にしたら敵じゃないでしょ
もうそれから抑えなくちゃいけない
治めなくちゃいけないだけで
この人々は一人も我々の政治には抵抗しなかった
だから敵じゃないんだと
だから守らなければいけないはめになります
それは仏教の犠牲の見方なんです
随分計算して物語で書いているんです
そのエピソードの中でも
王様をやっぱり捕まって殺すことに決めて
でも殺せないんだから
何も悪いことしていないんだから
で 池 何て言いますか この埋める池を埋めに決めるんです
で 生き埋めに決めても
やっぱり首を殺してはいけないんですね
殺してはいけないと 殺すことはできない
法律的にはということで攻撃しなかったこととだから戦争犯罪者になりません
だから今よりは昔は人間立派でしたからね
それで池を埋めにするんですけど
縦に埋めて首を上にして置いておく
だからもう中に埋めちゃう
死んじゃいますけどね
で 夜もうこれ遺体捨て場だからね
もういろいろ動物が来て遺体食べるし
王様のところに来たら
王様はもうこいつに食べられることがわかって
何のことなく頭がいいんだから
もう頭を上に上げたんです
上に上げちゃうと なんか狼みたいな動物が来て首を捕まったんです
キャットも死んでると思って首を捕まったら
どうせ王だから体力あるんだから
もう顎で押さえちゃったんです
頭を 動物の動物っていうのは体に力あるんですけど
頭の力がないんですよ
心らへんのは ほいできつく押さえられちゃうたら
もうどうにもならなくなっちゃって
この狼がもう必死でもうもがくんですね
逃げようと逃げようと
それで土がどんどんどんどんどんどん軽くなって
王様がまあ手を全部もう自由になって出て行って
何のことなく自分の宮殿に夜戻るんです
だからもう戦いない国だから警備もないし
軍隊も疲れてて寝ているし
何のことなく自分のベッドに寝たんです
自分のベッドには敵軍の王様が寝ているんです
で 横に寝たんです その時でもその人は起こさないで
で 殺せば殺されるでしょ
殺そうと思えば で 横になって寝たんです
王様として目が覚めてみたら
人間が寝ているんで怖くなっちゃって
誰かと思ったら王様なんです
池を埋めにした人がなんでここに？まあ別に何のことないんでしょうと
まああんたもう心配しないで寝てくださいと
夜だからと この王様言うんですね
それであの人の心が変わるんです
こんな人間いるのかと
私を殺そうとしたらいくらでも殺されたのに
何のことなく友達みたいに横になって寝ているのではないか
それで私 自分がすごい過ちを犯しましたと
攻撃する 絶対攻撃するべきではない人を攻撃したんだからということで
これから私の国も支配してくださいと
我々にも政治を教えてくださいって次の日は帰るんです
だから その場合でも ジャータカ物語はきれいに誰も犠牲にならない結果にするんです
なぜそこまでストーリーをいじるかというと
犠牲は認めてないんだからなんです
しかし 犠牲的な行為もすることにはなりなる
その時もちゃんとやってほしいという意味なんです
はい まあ食時間になりましたけど